deutsche medien hauptstadt am rheinufer
im szenebezirk ehrenfeld wohnen vor
allen dingen migranten und junge leute
im bunte burger gibt es alles außer
fleisch milch und käse
der imbiss ist deutschlands erste rein
vegane burger braterei
die gründer ulrich blendet und marco
binder haben sich damit einen traum
erfüllt
weil mir das ein herzensthema war dem
mario auch haben wir gesagt wir werden
im restaurant staaten nach einem veganes
restaurant und aber da nicht irgendwie
im zentrum das wort vegan stehen haben
das taucht bei uns auch gar nicht so auf
sondern bei uns steht geschmack im
mittelpunkt das wollen wir genauer
wissen also ab in die küche
hier werden gerade salat gewaschen und
süßkartoffel chips frittiert
doch john kampagne steht an der
radstation
das ist eine mächtige stück das ist ein
paniertes seiten schnitzel
wir machen die seiten auf frisch im haus
alle paar tage wird neu gemacht
seitan wurde ursprünglich von
chinesischen und japanischen zen
buddhisten als alternative zu fleisch
entwickelt und besteht aus weizeneiweiß
die alten pesto und das ist die mischung
aus frische petersilie süßer senf
sonnenblumenkern da drauf kommt schöne
frische salat auch alles aus der region
außerdem gurken und rote beete wir
bekommen fast täglich irgendwelche leute
die sich vielleicht mal ein bisschen
frieren haben und denken die bekommen
dann so eine fette saftiger rinder
bürger und das bekommen sie nicht bei
uns und wir empfehlen immer dann diese
bürde war dass es dann die fleisch
ähnlichen im gefühl im mund und bisher
sind keine so überzeugte fleisch presse
gegangen
die roten zwiebeln werden ganz
traditionell mit etwas zucker auf dem
grill karamellisiert bist
ganz am ende paris zwiebeln dafür nur
noch deckel vom grill noch sehr schön
warm
das ist er der könig ludwig alpen burger
und was sagen kunden über die
fleischlosen sarah ist einfach frische
zutaten bio zutaten aus der region und
die inhaber sind super nett und die
wollten unterstützen und nachhaltig
nachhaltiges essen genießen und selbst
den kritischsten es scheint es zu
schmecken